welcome back to GameSpot's coverage of
e3 2019 it is day two we have a bunch of
great games on stage baldur's gate three
outer worlds we're gonna be kicking off
shortly with modern warfare I'm gonna be
here all day I'm Mike McCarty here as
always with Lucy James hey and we are
here with Joel Emsley right from
infinity warden from working on modern
warfare studio art director you've been
bouncing back and forth kind of between
respawn and Infinity Ward for the past
few years I guess you could say but
you're back in seven years
yeah then slow but another yeah well we
just will keep it that way nice nice big
blocks of time to do a lot of good work
yeah well so now you're back working on
the modern warfare franchise it's like a
reboot accurate no no you know I think I
think when you when you look at the
trilogy of modern warfare there was it
ended in nuclear war and you you kind of
ended up with alternate reality yeah so
we wouldn't when actually when I heard
that Infinity Ward was making modern
warfare I immediately wanted to come
back to the studio and work on that was
really interested in it so when we came
back we took a look at it what are we
gonna do we we considered like a sequel
but it just didn't we had nowhere to go
it was almost an unrelatable reality
almost alternate reality so the idea was
to reimagine it like they would with
like Nolan's Batman or Casino Royale
yeah and kind of approach it that way so
that you had a lot more creative freedom
to do something and also make it more
relatable I mean we can set this game in
now like it's it's basically it takes
place now so but it it continues on like
the I guess like the spirit of the
modern warfare universe when you say
that you want to make it more relatable
obviously we have a lot of games I mean
watchdogs Legion for example you know
it's set in a post brexit world but
they're very conscious about not wanting
to get too political with any kind of
message are you feeling that pressure -
are you gonna lean into the sort of yeah
I think it's you know at the end of the
day it's a first-person shooter it's
supposed to be a fun game to play but I
think if you if you imagine that or if
you think that amara warfare is kind of
stepped up a little bit it
it's kind of grown out so the the
original trilogy was more based on like
80s action films and like you know
tongue-in-cheek a little bit here and
there that was that was perfect for that
time period or when those games were
coming out I mean the last smart warfare
that I worked on was 10 years ago that's
crazy to think and then he had modern
warfare 3 stuff puts us at 8 years so
the feat the franchise has been to bed
couldn't put the sleep for that long
almost a decade and the idea is you wake
it up now and you're dealing with fee
you know that the struggle so there that
the the headlines and things that are
happening today but it's still inspired
by it it's more like law and order like
how they would how they'd find
inspiration and stuff and creatively
integrated into the universe so inspired
by ripped from the headlines sort of but
yeah there's a struggle you you're
always trying to balance the the
friction that you get with making
something too much of a downer or too
much of a drag like you're still trying
to be a fun game to play it to but
raising the stakes would basically mean
making things more relatable and you
know you start caring about characters a
lot more you can you do that through
drama and you do it through a good story
it has to be believable and a little bit
more grown-up and with some of the stuff
we've seen so far and you've been
talking about when you're playable
characters will be I think in infinity
ward's words a freedom fighter you're
gonna be showing a different side of the
conflict you u-value imagine there's
challenges and telling that kind of
story as well yeah I mean we have we
have a character named Farah which i
think is really cool and you actually
when you meet her you start seeing her
history and playing from her perspective
actually this is really interesting
there's a there's like a 20 year
flashback to when she was a child
and there's an invasion that happens in
her inner city and you get to experience
it from her from her perspective I think
what's really interesting about Farah is
that you really start seeing why she
does what she does when you're fighting
with her as a character you you you
understand her where she's coming from
but I think it's there'd be the rebel
faction of the game is just basically
it's a tradition of Call of Duty of like
going back to the tier one side like we
used to just you know kind of jump
around and you would have liked the the
tight surgical stuff I think have like
the big bombastic you know
all out like weapons of like mastery
like crazy armor and stuff like that so
it's nice to counterbalance in that way
so you have be kind of be tighter
tactical moments in the game and you
have like the bigger moments to you also
kind of we're revisiting classic
characters and it's a reimagining if you
know Captain Price what's it like to
sort of revisit that character and put a
different spin on him but while staying
authentic to you know the price that we
all know and love I attempted prices and
the call did he won and you know he he
dies and called it he won and then when
I joined Infinity Ward it was called it
he to and priced made a comeback but
because it was a prequel and he he
plated larger role in that so those is
by the time we got to modern warfare
I had the assignment to kind of bring
Captain Price back and I had this whole
thing where I'm like you know really
like what I thought he died here and
they're like no just bring him back so
by now I think if we're talking two
incarnations I think I've said to our
incarnations we run the third
incarnation of Captain Price but this
time it's different
we're actually doing full motion capture
and performance capture with these with
these characters and we used to just
take Captain Price or a character like
Captain Price and draw them up concept
them and then they've signed a voice
actor to it so this time it's played by
Barry Sloane and Barry's gone through
SEAL training he's just he's a really
really cool guy and he's done his best
to kind of pay homage to Billy Murray's
Captain Price beforehand but seeing
seeing characters you know having them
actually act through and through I mean
Captain Price looks like Barry we
captured him he just has the beard and
everything too but it makes a huge
difference and kind of relating the
story to the player and actually making
you feel like you're with a badass or
like these characters or if it's a
villain you really start hating the
villain because the actor and the
actresses are really able to back into
the game it really showed up Call of
Duty 4 the original modern warfare is
kind of like set a standard for this
multiplayer progression that's become
the most pervasive thing in modern games
how do you return to modern warfare at
least the name and you know like you're
coming back to Infinity Ward to work on
the game how do you return to that and
also find out
like figure out a way to evolve that
formula it's in it's incredible I think
I can't go too much into it but we have
there's some key players from Modern
Warfare called it before
Jeff Smith Alex Roy sweats key map
designers Jeff is a game a multiplayer
director now what I've observed and been
involved with um you know supporting
that effort was you know it's been
ripped down to the studs and rebuilt up
all with this new engine that we have to
so I think the trick is to you know mark
Rigsby's back on the weapon handling and
all that stuff to the animation so I
don't know how to describe it when I
pick up this modern warfare there's
something about when you get all the all
these people and new people to together
in the right way the DNA is there and it
just feels like a mana warfare that the
handling that the smoothness of the
controls the way the gun reacts and then
we you do stuff to that to make it
additive to next level it so I mean I
could say right now that just just in
the weapon handling event we did things
like adding motion blur to the reetou
the recoil which makes it feel more
visceral and cool
there's more tactical reloads I'm I'm
spilling a little bit of beans here but
I'll say it anyway when you're aiming
down sight we made it so that you don't
have to come off the sight picture
there's just little little things like
that but I guess the the point is is
that you take everything that we had
before that made it great and he build
on it and make it out of it but he you
can't destroy the things that loved
about it people loved about it in the
first place it's tricky
it's tricky balance yeah let's talk a
little bit about the new engine so it's
been in development obviously for some
years what kind of what is that bringing
to Call of Duty there's this gonna be
the engine that you know all future
iterations across the studio is going to
be working with or is it just an
Infinity Ward I think the focus for us
has been you know the engine was in
development for about five years now
it wasn't development before modern
warfare started and I mean it I don't
know about the other other students the
focus is on mana warfare right now so I
don't know what the future holds for it
but it certainly gives us the ability to
do some things that I never dreamed of I
mean we have reactive cloth sim and the
characters and you know what they're
walking the run around like that we
talked about the ghillie suit yesterday
where it actually when they get up and
stand out things are moving the way you
would see it
miss fear explai a huge role in this
game and making it not only look
realistic but also being able to
identify targets in an environment which
it's really tricky in these games that
the higher fidelity games get sometimes
you can go too far with the noise and
that must fear plays a huge role in
knocking down you know the tones and the
temperatures and how things stack up in
the environment dimensionally and it's
crucial in a first-person shooter
you know multiplayer single-player
SpecOps to get all those to feel right
when you're actually engaging targets it
plays a huge role in that and actually
you know not frustrating people and then
the last thing is I mean there's more I
could go on forever we introduced
photogrametry which is reality capture
into the game and we use that to kind of
veneer the environment to make them feel
more realistic we have new mechanics in
the game like being able to mount up on
a corner or a sill or like vertical and
horizontal and when you get up close to
things like that you expect a level of
fidelity and so we have new things like
you were adding the sort of gramma tree
in there we're doing things like this
thing called micro tiling where you get
almost like you're used to looking at
like sixteen pixels per inch I'm totally
geeking out right now the old build the
old window so would be like sixteen
pixels per inch now we're looking at
nearly 64 pixels per inch with micro
tiling and so you use that to make it so
that when we're doing these new
mechanics and getting really close and
intimate with the environments it holds
up at that distance there's a kind of a
like multi-tiered question I guess but
as art director and as someone like
attached to a lot of different parts of
the design call duty as a series like
not just infinite warfare it's it's been
going toward this futuristic
progressively more futuristic each time
but now you're going back to more like I
don't want to say traditional it's like
the series started World War two but
modern warfare is traditional compared
to nowadays from an art perspective does
that like kind of just going back in
time allow you anything
that you couldn't do the sci-fi stuff
the sci-fi just gives you kind of like
it's a veneer that you can kind of maybe
using this as an excuse if you want to
talk about like story things also like
you start getting into space magic yeah
and that's fun
there's nothing wrong with that I
actually I got a lot out of the
experience working on you know more more
fantasy science fiction stuff in the
last seven years and brought that in to
modern warfare so I I used to do a lot
of maquette making and kit bashing and
things with model kits and things to get
certain looks but since we moved into
reality capture I
I went from 1/6 scale to 1 to 1 scale
for this game and I start encouraging
the art department to kind of take part
in Hollywood Hollywood style kit bashing
with costume that we have in an actual
wardrobe at an affinity award now you
know all the costumes and then you you
look at the gear and stuff so I guess
you can still come at it from a
Hollywood perspective artistically but I
think that you know there's still game
play and things like that to kind of
answer answer to mechanics and things we
keep it as real as possible but there's
still stuff like I don't know maybe
there you would see a heartbeat sensor
the game or something like that but we
do what we do is try to take things like
that and grind it down to something that
looks like it belongs in a real steel
armory does that does that like retread
to more current times kind of feel
limiting dollars that a good limiting
like whether it's through game play or
art or story it's like now again with a
story you don't have that sci-fi thing
to say oh it's sci-fi it's not like
we're we're not like modern warfare
you're literally saying oh it's kind of
happening now right I don't know is that
does that constraint breed creativity or
is it feel pretty limiting it breeds
creativity I think I mean I I like I
like having the constraints of reality
on us and I like the way that I like
when things have to feel physical and
you have to figure that out so something
like look let's say we have let's let's
say we have a wheeled drone running
around you know you see them all the
time and
and military documentaries and stuff
like that but look we would have to like
build something like that and explain it
and design it so that it fits our
universe every part on it has to be
believable so I guess you have a you
have a fantastic visual library to draw
from and still work with it I I think
you're you still have a lot I mean you
look at something like Sicario and how
how visually creative that looks we had
thing yeah I don't feel any restraints
on it I think it's it's still
entertainment it's still art I was asked
the other day about a character that we
have in a level that we're showing
behind closed doors here and this big
character booms in the room and we we
could have just made that soldier look
kind of normal but I chose to make it
more of a metaphor so we chose this huge
with one of our one of our character
artists is actually a professional or a
competitive bodybuilder so I said I want
this character to come into the room and
be memorable and so we we kidded him out
and you know scanned him and got him in
the game and it changed from this moment
where he it could have been super
realistic and and constricting and kind
of you know not as memorable too
realistic and we took a moment and I
think we made it way more memorable by
upping the costume and taking a little
bit of creative freedom so I guess I
guess what I'm saying is even reality
you still have a lot of ways to go with
making it memorable and and being free
and being you know really exploring
things so take a step back earlier you
mentioned you know flirting with
Hollywood in terms of techniques and
inspirations and call of duty is one of
those I guess ran franchises that has
really hit the mainstream like you can
talk to anyone and they will know what
Call of Duty is and that's kind of fed
into having celebrities be in the game
so obviously Kit Harington as a most
recent example is are we gonna see any
kind of really famous faces coming to
Modern Warfare any I'm sorry any kind of
huge celebrities coming to modern
warfare not that I know ever can talk
about now I mean we have our we have our
main cast Barry Sloane
Claudia doom it I'm trying to remember
everybody's name we
chad michael collins we my last one
Elliot knight so I've got my four main
main cast there they're there they've
been I mean they're they're celebrities
on their own and been doing things but
you know I think it's in service of the
narrative yeah it's well I can give you
imagine you know a few years ago when
every every game had some celebrity was
a bit weird and then you kind of get
huge celebrities appearing in games and
actually you know I Keanu Reeves in
cyberpunk it's kind of just yeah that's
probably the biggest surprise the show
so far Joel unfortunately we are at a
time thank you so much for joining us
good luck with the months leading up to
the release of quality modern warfare
and if you're watching at home we will
be right back after a very short break
with oculus as Jason Rubin see you then
[Music]
[Applause]